vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure à voir
restituer à un pin's est ce celui du
gspr par ailleurs collaborateur du
président de la république
vous bénéficiez d'une habilitation
secret défense au terme d'une enquête
menée par le sgdsn
quand avez-vous rempli et signé le
formulaire de demande combien de fois
quand et par qui
avez vous été auditionné pour obtenir
votre accréditation de secret défense et
enfin le début et la fin de votre
accréditation secret défense aux roses
ont ils été notifiés si oui quand alors
super nanas en ce qui concerne le pin's
j'ai entendu aussi beaucoup de choses et
lu beaucoup de choses dans la presse en
aucun cas le pin's qui est porté par les
membres du cabinet de la présidence de
la république n'est similaire à celui du
gspr le pin's du j'espère est un pin's
noir avec les armoiries de la présidence
et 3 étoiles qui signifie c'est
l'acronyme de la protection rapprochée
le pin's qui est délivré aux membres du
cabinet et ainsi qu'à certaines
personnes des services administratifs
comme les photographes les intendants
qui met ce pin cela pour être identifier
plus facilement lors des déplacements du
président de la république est un pin's
rompt avec les couleurs bleu blanc rouge
et la mention présidence de la
république dessus il est numéroté et il
est attribué nominativement par le
commandement militaire du palais de
l'elysée sur instruction du directeur de
cabinet en ce qui concerne l' enquête
d'habilitation elle n'a pas été
effectuée par le sgdsn le gds n
effectuent les enquêtes simplement pour
les habilitations très secret défense ce
dont je n'étais pas habilités j'ai été
habilités par mon autorité d'emploi
c'est-à-dire le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république sur rapport
de la dgs et la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure dont je pense que
les enquêtes sont assez poussées et dont
je ne connais pas la nature
c'est par essence le but quand on
procède à des enquêtes de ce type là en
ce qui concerne la notification d'une
feinte d'habilitation l'habilitation
étant donné dès lors que vous occuper
des fonctions à la fin de vos fonctions
lé cas du elle devient caduque et c'est
le cas dans l'administration
quand quelqu'un est sur un poste qui
nécessite une habilitation secret
défense
et qu'il quitte ce poste pour prendre
une nouvelle fonction il n'est plus
habilité comme il l'était avant
l'habilitation dépend du poste que vous
occupez monsieur hervé veut compléter
celles que vous voulez dire que vous
n'avez à aucun moment été auditionné
entendu en vue d'une habilitation secret
défense au démarrage de votre choix de
l'elysée alors sans trahir de secrets en
ce qui concerne les habitations ce que
moi même je n'en suis pas détenteurs la
seule fois où intervient une audition
dans le cadre d'une habilitation s'est
dès lors qu'il ya un problème dès lors
qu'il y a un problème qui est soulevée
par les services dont ils viennent ils
vous demandent de répondre à une
convocation qu'elle voudrait déferré et
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions qu'ils se posent sur des
failles susceptibles de vous un pacte
est donc n'ayant pas été auditionné par
ses services c'est qu'il n'y avait
aucune raison de douter
ou en tout cas de mme auditionné sur des
faits qui auraient été portées à leur
connaissance
madame 3 engley merci monsieur le
président monsieur ben alla vous nous
avez dit le tout à l'heure quand on a la
question a été posée sur le téléphone
théorème que vous aviez le souci du
respect des procédures
ma question porte sur la le moment où
vous avez récupéré vaut au passeport
diplomatique
vous nous avez dit que pour vos
déplacements il vous arrive est
d'informer des personnes très haut
placées à l'elysée de vos déplacements
est-ce que c'était lié à une procédure
et je m'en explique
est ce qu'on vous a demandé est ce que
quelqu'un vous a demandé de tenir
informé de vos déplacements
sinon qu'est-ce qui a pu vous motiver
qu'est-ce qui a pu expliquer votre
démarche auprès de ces personnes
sinon que le président de la république
en soient informés je vais jusqu'au bout
de ma question peut-être ce n'est pas du
tout votre démarche
et est-ce que vous avez infirmer ces
personnes lorsque vous êtes allés au
tchad
je vais ne la non pour répondre à votre
question
j'avais aucune obligation d'informer la
présidence de la république de mes
déplacements je les fais par courtoisie
et paradoxalement je les fais pour
éviter ce qu'on est en train de vivre
aujourd'hui
et l'erreur de ma part de l'utilisation
des passeports n'a pas aidé en soi à
l'idée c'était que quand je me déplace
connaissant la notoriété qu'a provoqué
un peu cette affaire qu' il n'y ait
aucune interprétation du à ses
déplacements en l'occurrence je ne
l'avais pas été informé du déplacement
presse du président de la république
trois semaines après le mien au tchad et
[Musique]
l'elysée a été informé de ce déplacement
au tchad
postérieurement parce que je devais
effectuer
serge et je suis allé au tchad et je les
ai informés que j'avais été au chat je
les ai pas informé avant d'y aller c'est
ce qu'a provoqué ensuite toute cette
histoire
voilà mais je n'avais aucune obligation
à le faire je vais fait par courtoisie
voilà madame traîne les voulait rebondir
vous l'avez fait par courtoisie pour que
le président de la république en soit
informé monsieur ménard
non je les fais surtout pour fne
services sont informés et que
l'entourage du président de la
république le soit également de manière
à ce qu' il n'y ait pas de conclusion
est qu'on soit un minimum au courant de
ce que je faisais a déçu de mon
licenciement
monsieur fichiers oui merci monsieur le
président tu as voulu revenir simplement
quelques instants sur l'histoire du
téléphone théorème on nous a expliqué
ici qu'il y avait quatre mille 600
appareils
en fonctionnement à l'échelon national
une trentaine qui était au niveau de
l'elysée et que l'utilisation de ce
téléphone nécessité que le correspondant
est le même téléphone
donc on est sur quelque chose qui est
extrêmement cadré extrêmement précis et
je voudrais savoir si vous avez eu
l'utilisation fréquente de ce type de
téléphone est le cas c'est chiant avec
quel type de correspondants et comment
vous expliquer qu'un téléphone aussi
important aussi rare cryptée puis cet
égard et pendant plusieurs semaines
voire mois et que vous le retrouviez par
hasard dans vos cartons alors que vous
ne paraissez par ailleurs six sous
que d'être professionnel et de bien
utiliser le matériel dû le rendre en
temps voulu c'est vrai que c'est quand
même un outil très précieux et rare
alors c'est un coup de finale à alors
c'est un geste un outil comme vous
l'avez dit qui a coûté très cher à
l'état et qui est très peu utilisé
malheureusement alors qu'il est à la
disposition de toutes les personnes qui
en ont besoin moi je me déplaçais
j'organisais des déplacements j'étais en
lien avec des autorités préfectorales
des autorités de police donc j'en avais
une utilité et c'était avec ces
personnes là que j'ai changé en ce qui
concerne le pourquoi il appelle je n'ai
pas retrouvé par hasard j'ai retrouvé
parce qu'après avoir reçu le courrier du
directeur de cabinet et je voulais être
sûr et certain que je n'avais plus roulé
en ma possession appartenant à la
présidence de la république
donc les retrouver par des recherches de
manière à pouvoir le rendre de manière
spontanée ce qui a été fait par mon
avocate
j'explique pas le fait qu' il se soit
rendu compte que ce téléphone n'était
plus à le mois d'octobre en tout cas moi
je n'ai jamais été informé ni sollicitée
par quiconque pour le restituer je les
fais de ma propre initiative
comme je lé fais pour les passeports
diplomatiques après l'éclatement du
scandale et via mon avocate
voilà ce que je peux vous dire monsieur
le sénateur merci monsieur benalla
monsieur françois noël buffet merci
monsieur le président et ce benalla vous
êtes licencié le 1er août 2018
vous bénéficiez de passeport
diplomatique ou de service qui vous
donnent naturellement qu'ils sont liés à
votre fonction pendant la période du 1er
août au 31 décembre vous voyagez 20 fois
à 20 reprises 23 fois précisément vous
avez dit tout à l'heure voyager à titre
personnel pour mener des missions
personnel dont vous considérez
d'ailleurs qu'elle ne regarde pas la
commission ce qu'on peut partager
naturellement on vous demande le
gouvernement en tous les cas vous
demande à deux reprises à partir du mois
d'octobre de restituer ces passeports
les lettres qui vous seront envoyées ne
seront pas retirés
vous ètes semble-t-il soucieux
de la régularité des choses vous l'avait
redit
trouvez vous normal cette situation de
voyager à titre personnel avec des
passeports qui était lié à la fonction
que vous n'occupez plus est ce que ça
vous paraît normal de beynat
alors juste pour repréciser un monsieur
le sénateur ce que je pense que vous
êtes garé au niveau des dates
j'ai reçu les correspondances du
ministère des affaires étrangères à la
fin du mois de juillet 2018 plus un mail
du général bio farina qui me demandait
de restituer un certain nombre
d'affaires
j'ai restituer ses affaires dans le
courant du mois d'août 2018 et quand ces
passeports ont été rendus début octobre
je n'ai après plus jamais reçu de
relance de la part du mystère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères on
m'a rendu ces passeports en l'état
utilisable sans aucune interdiction de
les utiliser si ce n'est un cadre que je
qualifierais de morale et dont j'assume
la responsabilité aujourd'hui c'était
une bêtise de les utiliser donc ce n'est
pas normal et vous avez raison de le
souligner monsieur le sénateur ce
n'était pas normal d'utiliser ces
passeports
je les fait et j'en assume la
responsabilité devant vous et devant la
justice également